[Music]
in taking over news a submitted by mr.
and mrs. Smith oh that was a lot of
sexual tension you could feel it that's
why they got married
it got snubbed you know ward season yeah
Wilson yeah they probably hate [ __ ] each
other
yeah when there's no guns involved the
love is gone ah you like that I bet you
got daddy issues when we have a daughter
when we have a daughter I will make sure
that she has a little bit of daddy
issues firown' sink it in Tigers can
take full advantage of it
whoa pump your brakes pump your brakes
you ready marrying I'll be such a
diverse child always super super to mix
our kid married their kid right come on
Apartments gonna do right get so many
scholarships all right I'm with it good
God okay cool
does that kid learn how to make the food
that's wet okay all right a man with OCD
describes the terror of his disorder oh
I bet dude so helps you know what's even
more terror being around people with OCD
it sounds like it's very personal to you
would you like to share I'm so
personally ignorant of this subject that
when I see like a little babies for
example just likes arranging things in a
line like our knees like her knees I'm
like that I should think that because I
don't know anything about it no my mom
thought I was autistic for a little bit
when I was a kid I used to do this stuff
I line up all but I would keep all the
McDonald's toys you get in Happy Meals
you know and I'd have a whole bin of
them and I would line them up one by one
like in order and then I would line up
like different things like remote
controls and stuff after that and then I
would move one inch that I moved the
next one oh yeah I would think the same
thing like oh my god Tyco
is gonna have a learning disability of
some sorry yeah exactly
turns out I'm just super super smart sax
anyway that's what happened to me too
yes my parents were so stupid they
didn't recognize the genius and they
thought that I was trouble they're like
you're a freak mm-hmm we used to line
[ __ ] up like that man what did you do I
was just being me would it be in you
mean I was just existing and they
thought I was stupid okay
I don't even know what I did what the
[ __ ] that's I caught can you can someone
hug in not too much Ezz this was a
friend pad it was friend okay
yeah her hands were open I saw her okay
all right yeah that was like a sister
hug all right I wish I was really that
guy's sister fist bump yeah you wanna
really I want to be that guy so bad yeah
I wanna I wanna have like a monster
energy drink decal on the back of my
truck you drive like a big [ __ ] Ford
Raptor I want to be the guy what's weird
is that you actually want a Ford Raptor
and you drink monster all but I know
what you're talking about
that's weird [ __ ] proud of your [ __ ]
monsters on their car that's [ __ ]
weird exactly you may keep your bouncers
in your closet you've been to one
motocross rally or a real WWE event and
not for the joke of it yeah I'm worried
that is yeah that's the kind of guy
they've got here his name is Brandon
he's 22 years old he's a Brooklyn
photographer and he was just retelling
his experience with his OCD so he was
saying that Hugh would have his thoughts
so jumbled in his head that it was
almost like he had voices but it had
actually just been his OCD and so
usually OCD is associated with like
repetitive actions
yeah real OCD you know everyone goes
like oh I got a TDR
oh I got OCD cuz I gotta do this I don't
see do see because I have a family
friend that has real OCD and he's always
washing his hands to the point where he
has [ __ ] like all day yeah because it
gets all dried up
yeah and then he always feels dirty so
he has to wash so you can't even put
lotion then no it's all [ __ ] up it was
like dirty all the time he probably
bleaches his hands too [ __ ] they do that
view and then like their skins like Oh
anyway yeah that's it is that used to
beat him or not
oh my goodness so he washes his hands
now it's cut it's like a weird man is
bit like you're trying to clean yourself
that's like a weird like like he
couldn't pass the exam the what was it
the MCAT or the I'm Canada yeah he keep
in Khafre doc yeah yeah I was four
dollars answer then like yeah because of
the pressure like he's an intelligent
guy but he just kind of watch my [ __ ]
hands and then he freaks out before the
test and like almost gets like a heart
attack and [ __ ] damn that sucks yes
that's real OCD well you know the people
that are arranging [ __ ] all day you're
just on meth that's true yeah all of you
yeah so Brandon here he has a specific
form of OCD called scrupulosity
scrupulosity velocity it sounds like a
website that even book travel on how
would you avoid traveling with velocity
thank you for using it it focuses more
on religious or moral perfectionism so
for him he was plagued with thoughts of
the devil and he was like horrified by
the color red and even like them so he
hates Chinese New Year it's like Carrie
yeah not a fan of the journey yeah even
the number six and he was like super
cautious about his food and to the point
where he stopped eating entirely he
would he dropped to like 107 pounds
lucky it was best gift I'm kidding it's
a nice number I will say that's a good
number
at least it wasn't a hundred six pounds
see what oh yeah that's me papa donut
and he's like all [ __ ] into clothes
he should have became like 777 pounds
then he would be super Kylie mm-hmm and
probably did oh yeah what's the record
bro well good at seven seven seven yeah
that's the thing he's saying that at
first I get started with like hand
picking and like weird habits with his
skin and then I developed to him being
really cautious with the food in terms
of contamination and then also like he
started having these thoughts in his
head where it would
his thoughts would tell him like oh if
you take a bite of that thing like it's
Satan it's only selling your soul to be
devil's food bud
yeah that's what this is called right
right that's that's what he's a dessert
I wish I had that voice telling me when
I you know want to lose weight and like
stay away from unhealthy food that's how
eating disorder is yeah I mean it's like
that oh you hear these voices huh well
it's like yeah well you feel so guilty
and then like and then you remember the
what you ate like the whole time and
like you know exactly what you ate like
I had two bites of chicken I had one pea
I had you know three broccoli stems I
had yeah and you remember everything you
know how much cat home okay I wish I had
that you know you know it's cuz my
guilty conscience works in cahoots with
my pleasure suicide yeah so like I feel
like you shouldn't eat that ice cream
you know you getting fatter but today's
a holiday so I live a little yeah come
on reasonable though that sounds like
normal okay yeah that's how he wishes he
had a voice telling him that like they
were stirred yeah yeah together too much
you know they should be fighting but
yeah they like the compromise we have a
little bit because they both want it you
know yeah my my brain is basically like
shaggy from scooby-doo he's like this
and be fine yeah that's [ __ ]
everything for everything that's like
pretty much that's it yeah and so he was
just thinking also that he would start
writing like crosses like drawing
crosses on things and writing out Bible
verses and pacing them on his walls it's
like that guy on the what was that movie
where he whips himself oh yeah Vinci
cows will treasure treasure the Vinci
Code do me go by no got it yeah yeah
yeah da Vinci Code Paul Bettany yeah
yeah and then by the time you turn 17
Brandon here he started having more than
5,000 compulsions a day and he had to
drop out of high school shoes yeah so
like it's a living nightmare every day
yeah exactly
so finally he was able to I mean he
still struggles with OCD till his day
but it's gotten better because he went
to go get help and then this doctor that
helped him he started having him
undertake exercises to control his fears
like covering his entire room with
sticky notes that face Satan or 666 and
then like - like signing a fake contract
selling your soul to the Satan do a
pentagram sacrifice a [ __ ] goat means
I can I feel better soon why didn't he
ever think his doctor was Satan like I
was worried that if that my doctor was
telling me that like I would think he
was Satan and I try to kill a
neighborhood cat drain all of its blood
into a pen to do whatever you think is
good do the opposite of that yeah
then you'll be cured so you don't care
you but yeah yes yeah I would think he
was Satan this is Brandon he looks good
yeah just like a regular dude Wow he
doesn't look a hundred and seven pounds
no at one point
oh yeah this must be this must have been
his cheat day no Sam that was his cheat
day enter in the picture I know that's
it can you imagine like having a
condition where you don't control your
own thoughts and mind and it's just
everything is [ __ ] autopilot and and
you you're just observing yourself doing
these things and you don't want to
that's [ __ ] that's super crazy or
like people have like schizophrenia and
all that you're like the complexions are
too yeah you know yeah I guess I could
relate yeah you really rationalize
things you like yeah yeah you guys are
seeing Donnie Darko yeah yeah yeah every
time I think about like voices and your
head I always think of him hmm but it's
fun too it sounds like he's miserable
cuz like sometimes I'm like I know I
should stop gambling cuz I already made
because I want damn this is really
serious already but I could win and turn
this into more money
oh man I knew I should have quit oh well
that's your brain and the other thing
going yeah yeah at least my brain wants
to do an expensive [ __ ] like he's like
let's go Taco Bell again and I'm like oh
thank you my brains always like you
didn't do enough today it's like Asian
daddy no I do I really do like day you
did at work yeah it was like oh my god I
got eight out of ten things done I'm
like to do this like why didn't you get
the other two done why don't you get
twelve done why did you get twelve out
of eight done
yeah nothing it's not welcome you do 50
things yeah I know how to do I had to
like really condition myself to be like
like this year especially like I'm gonna
be happy with whatever I got done it's
really hard
oh you're about to cry no not I could
though at any point I just argue with
myself if they say that I'll be like
shut up bad
[Laughter]
[Music]